the app that's taken Teenagers by storm
is used by millions of Americans
allegations that they're being used to
spy on users if the Trump has accused
Tick Tock of being part of this
information campaigns that benefits
China represents a threat to U.S
national security foreign policy and the
U.S economy I'm just very very very
convinced that Tick Tock is spying on me
new Elite information shows that tick
tock's parent company bite dance was
planning on using tiktok's location data
to spy on the physical location of
specific Americans let me explain ah yes
Tick Tock the Chinese app that has been
saying for years that they do not spy on
Americans well as it turns out that is a
big fat lie see tiktok isn't really the
one calling the shots it's their Chinese
parent company bite dance that is
calling the shots a Chinese Tech Giant
that has the answer to the every beck
and call of the Chinese government bike
dance has an internal auditing that
literally spies on current and former
employees for potential misconduct they
had people inside Tick Tock saying
everything is seen in China they had a
master admin person who again was was
disclosing that there was almost no
checks on what could go back there it's
important to understand that all
technology companies ultimately answer
to the governments of the countries in
which they exist where they're based and
where they operate China is a far less
free country and is far less protection
of people's rights and people's personal
information from the government so the
issue isn't whether right now Tick Tock
is feeding information for the Chinese
government it's that they potentially
could be doing so if the government so
wanted that is not all that surprising
being that it's a Chinese Tech Giant but
what is surprising is that thanks to
some whistleblowers on the inside it's
now been revealed that the internal
audit team also plan to track the
location of specific Americans via that
neat little app called Tick Tock you
have installed on your phone what kind
of specific Americans and why are they
being targeted you ask Forbes didn't say
to protect their sources on the inside
but I think you and I can probably guess
maybe it's the spy on people that walk
up other competing social platforms some
good old corporate Espionage or maybe
it's for something far more Sinister
like the spy on US government officials
activists public figures or maybe even
journalists the Department of Homeland
Security the Pentagon and the state
department have all banned the use of
tick tock creates a massive
vulnerability of information that can be
data mined makes it easier to Target
people it makes it easier for
intelligence service to either recruit
or hack into systems used by a
government employee at the FCC we've
also taken a look at other entities
beholden to the CCP whether it's Huawei
ZTE China mobile and we see just a
history of Nefarious conduct on Business
Industrial Espionage to Blackmail
there's a lot of reasons to be concerned
not about the videos but the underlying
data going back in Mass to China but of
course Tick Tock has denied all these
allegations saying that we weren't gonna
spy on specific Americans locations we
only collect approximate location data
to quote help show relevant content and
ask the users comply with applicable
laws and detect and prevent fraud and
inauthentic Behavior End quotes when in
reality Forbes confirmed that the
materials share with them showed that
bite dance was not going to use its
location data to serve relevant ads or
something innocent like that but to
literally quote surveil individual
American citizens End quotes this is the
Chinese Communist Party using data sets
for purposes of their their own National
Security through the control of the
algorithm China is able to influence
American public opinion we know that in
2020 the Chinese military used Tick-Tock
to incite violence on American streets
Tick Tock glorifies drug usage in
America and there are other things that
they've been doing to interfere in our
political process with that data China
is able to feed it into its artificial
intelligence systems is also perhaps
able to compromise America yeah Tick
Tock is way worse than you could have
ever imagined the Chinese government has
tentacles and tick tocks are way more
than you could have imagined stay
dangerous and this is everything they
don't want you to know about tick tock
[Music]
Tick Tock is now worth almost a third of
a trillion dollars and it all started
because they saw the trend the Gap in
the marketplace for short form video
that is the power of jumping on Trends
early the problem is fighting trends
that are just about to pop off is really
hard but lucky for you that is where
Trends comes in Trends puts you on the
next big startup ideas months before
everyone else hears about them that's
because Trends has a team of top
business analysts that vet thousands of
upcoming startup ideas and market trends
for you and then they take the best ones
that are about to blow up and they email
them to you every week they've already
outlined over 8 000 vetted business
ideas that you can start in just a
weekend plus by signing up you'll also
get access to their Trends community
that has over 15 000 ambitious
like-minded people just like you that
you can collab with to turn these ideas
into reality we are headed into a
recession right now but if you're trying
to start a business that's actually a
good thing Apple Airbnb Microsoft
Netflix Uber and many more were all
started during a recession so if there's
a time to start finding the next big
thing it's right now and trans is the
number one resource for the job just
take the the wreck for example he was a
trans member who used their research to
raise 1.5 million dollars in funding and
what's cool is that it normally costs
299 a year to get access to trenza's
valuable insight and Community but if
you use my link below right now you'll
get a 7-Day trial of trends for just one
dollar and plus even if you had to pay
299 right off the bat all it takes is
just one great business idea from Trends
and it would pay for itself anyways so
pause the video and click the link below
to get started right now thanks to
trends for sponsoring this video
[Music]
Chinese government's Grand Masterpiece
for infiltrating and manipulating the
West Tick Tock was far from bite Dance's
first try at surveillance and propaganda
for the Chinese Communist party as
you'll see bite Dance's entire history
is about serving as the Chinese
government's surveillance propaganda and
censorship arm
bite dance had created this insane
machine learning algorithm that adjusted
someone's news feed based on the things
they liked spent the most time on and
other preferences and years before
tiktok came around bite dance would use
this very same algorithm in a bunch of
different apps that it released all over
the world but like any Chinese tech
company they learned very quickly that
if their products couldn't somehow serve
the interest of the CCP the apps would
just get shut down at one point the
founder even had to publicly apologize
for not serving his country better and
promised that all bite dances technology
would be quote guided end quote by CCP
values in the future a year before Tick
Tock was released bite dance launched a
news app that became pretty popular in
the US top buzz it was basically The
Tick Tock algorithm but for news
headlines in top Buzz employees
basically were forced to only promote
Pro occp content with the unspoken
understanding that if they didn't quote
somebody was going to jail end quote but
they were smart about this they knew
that no one in the west would be
interested in seeing a bunch of super
pro Chinese news so they only promoted
soft pro-china messages instead of overt
political statements their bosses were
so paranoid about not angering the CCP
they even made top Buzz employees share
screenshots of all the content they
posted so they could be sure they
weren't stepping on anyone's toes
anything even a little critical of the
government like posts covering the
protests in Hong Kong would be taken
down immediately and when bite dance
bought another Chinese app called
musically and merged it with the early
stage version of tick tock they were
forced to take the same exact approach
as top Buzz employees were given
guidelines for Content restriction
targeted material to censor included the
Hong Kong protest best in 2019 Tibet and
religious minority groups anything that
would not please Beijing was either
suppressed or simply deleted but once
Tick Tock became popular Americans
started getting suspicious with Donald
Trump threatening to ban Tick Tock
altogether if they didn't sever ties
with China which put tiktok in a tricky
position between two powerful countries
who both wanted control of the billion
dollar app if bite dance wanted
Tick-Tock to survive and thrive in the
U.S they were going to need to do
everything in their power to make it
look like they had no control over Tick
Tock that Tick Tock really was an
independent American company completely
separate from bite dance and by
extension the Chinese government
so Tick Tock started systematically
covering up their ties to China
Unfortunately they did not do a very
good job so whistleblowers and Tick-Tock
employees started sharing a completely
different story
according to Tick-Tock employees in
their work Tick Tock invite dance are
tied so closely together that it's
almost impossible to tell quote where
one ends and another begins end quote
that boundaries between the two
companies are quote almost non-existent
end quote Tick-Tock recruiters actually
hire people to work in both companies at
once new hires have email accounts for
both Tick Tock and bite dance and both
companies even use the same workplace
apps to communicate and share
information so to say that Tick Tock
makes its own decisions about running
the company without influence from China
yeah that's a little more than
stretching the truth that's more like an
outright lie even in America Tick Tock
employees have reported working double
shifts and staying up all night so they
could be available to answer questions
for executives in Beijing
game-changing product decisions don't go
forward without quote talking to Jing
end quote over and over again these
mysterious people in Beijing are making
key leadership decisions for tick tock
and these American employees don't even
know who their Beijing managers actually
are even though Tick Tock claims it
doesn't answer to the CCP fight dances
company policy agrees to share internal
company Communications with governments
including the Chinese government when it
deems necessary you know for things like
assisting in law enforcement or
government investigations it's all part
of being a good responsible company
after all never mind the fact it's
written in Chinese law multiple times
that if they don't report or Surrender
data to the CCP when asked they stand to
lose everything or that Tick Tock
employees were asked to submit sensitive
information to dot CN domains the key
Internet domain for the People's
Republic of China like dot us or dot gov
for the United States and bite dance
doesn't even have to go through Tick
Tock to access tick tock's user data
turns out that if a Tick-Tock employee
is struggling to find something in their
database they can just ask a data team
in China for help because all of tick
tock's data is accessible to Beijing
without Tick Tock needing to give
authorization which is the exact
opposite of what Tick Tock has claimed
in what ways does the government of the
People's Republic of China exercise
influence over tick tock's corporate
behavior in no way shape or form period
in no way shape or form period Tick Tock
responded to these accusations by saying
that Chinese bite dance employees can
access sensitive us data as long as they
have been authorized to do so by a
us-based security team but this
completely ignores the fact that this
same us team must also report to bite
dance leadership in Beijing in order to
do anything but yes that U.S based
security team definitely does have
authority over their Beijing leaders and
after 80 meetings at Tick Tock were
recorded and leaked showing that U.S
user data has been repeatedly accessed
from China and dozens of tick-tock
employees started blowing the whistle
things were not looking good for tick
tock they've had to find a way to make
the American public and politicians
happy or else they would have to kiss
the lucrative American Market goodbye
they needed to make Tick Tock come off
just a little more American
[Music]
ah yes project Texas fight Dances all in
attempt to save face with the American
public and government because what could
be more American than Texas
and Tick Tock loves talking about it
every chance they get you may be
familiar with project Texas see after
all the whistleblowing and controversy
Tick Tock turned to Oracle a Microsoft
partner for Help by working with Oracle
Tick Tock claims that they will move 100
percent of U.S users data to oracle's
Cloud a massive server located in Austin
Texas see everyone all your data is
going to be stored safely right here in
the U.S and in Texas no less look at how
American we are now right
Tick Tock keeps claiming that this way
Oracle will be a source of
accountability a way to verify that no
their user data isn't accessed by China
but according to Oracle this isn't
actually the case they have other big
name clients that they provide this
service for like Bank of America General
Motors and a bunch of others and like
all these other customers Tick Tock will
still have full control of everything
that happens with their user data with
no input from Oracle this lines up with
Elite conversation from an ex-tick talk
employee quote it's almost incorrect to
call it Oracle Cloud because they're
just giving us bare metal and then we're
building our VMS or virtual machines on
top of it end quote Oracle doesn't
actually get to see anything that Tick
Tock or bite dance sees they just
provide the servers for them to use as
they see fit tiktok has tried other ways
to show that project Texas
a declaration of independence from its
Chinese Roots there's a special team
running project Texas and according to
Tick-Tock Executives Chinese Nationals
are not allowed to be part of it but
while the special us team is tasked with
protecting sensitive American user data
it conveniently still has to report to
Beijing and the claim that 100 percent
of U.S user data is going to be in this
new safe home in Texas turns out that's
a lie too most of the data will also be
stored at a center in Virginia where
bite dances offices in Beijing will
continue to have access no matter how
much effort Tick Tock puts into hyping
its shiny new makeover the fact remains
physical location does not matter as
long as bite dance and by extension the
CCP is part of the picture China can do
whatever it wants inside those data
centers but if you thought that was it
you are sadly mistaken
foreign
[Music]
specifically programmed to monitor
keystrokes something that even other
apps like Instagram and Facebook
Messenger don't do when Tick-Tock users
click on a link in the app and use tick
tock's in-app browser Tick Tock is
monitoring all your keystrokes on
whatever website you're browsing this
includes whatever you type or click on a
page anything you type into a website
your credit card information your
password your age home address or even
political party depending on the website
Tick Tock can capture it all many cyber
Security Experts are disturbed by how
sneaky this programming is quote the
assumption that your data is being
pre-read before you even submit it I
think that crosses a line end quote out
of the seven major social media apps
tested Tick Tock was the only one that
did this and none of the others
monitored nearly as much activity as
tick tock
despite all of this Tick Tock is close
to signing an agreement with the US to
allow it to continue operations even
while it remains under investigation
Tick Tock is already banned in India
Australia has launched its own
investigation and Ireland is now doing
the same see China understands a
fundamental truth what the masses
consume they become so what does China
feed the masses in the west dancing
videos soft while China's version of
tick tock they feed their masses
educational videos videos about science
technology the Arts people being
outstanding members of society
it's it's almost it's quite literally as
if Xi Jinping saw the social dilemma
because they've in the last two months
rolled out a bunch of sweeping reforms
that include things like
if you're under the age of 14 and you
use doyan which is their version of tick
tock when you swipe the videos instead
of getting like the influencer dancing
videos and soft pornography you get
science experiments you can do at home
Museum exhibits and patriotism videos
wow so you're scrolling and you're
getting stuff that's educating because
they want their kids to grow up and want
to be astronauts and scientists yeah
they don't want them to grow up and be
influencers they also limit it to
um three hours sorry 40 minutes a day on
Tick Tock for gaming let me actually do
the tick tock example so they do 40
minutes a day for tick tock they also
when you scroll a few times they
actually do a mandatory five second
delay saying hey do you want to get up
and do something else
um China said hey we don't want people
mindlessly scrolling so after you scroll
a few videos it does a mandatory five
second like interlude they also have
opening hours and closing hours so from
10 pm until six in the morning if you're
under 14 it's like it's closed
it's easy for this YouTube channel to
cover corruption fraud and censorship
between bite dance in China but there
are some topics that are just a little
too disturbing to cover in a public
video without getting demonetized like
China's profitable business of forced
organ harvesting where they harvest the
organs of prisoners to sell to wealthy
westerners in need of an organ
transplant that way people don't have to
wait years on a western transplant
waiting list obviously this video
wouldn't fly on YouTube so we released
it as a private documentary available
only to members of this Channel and you
can watch it right now by clicking the
join button below it's by far our most
disturbing documentary yet we're really
proud of it and you get a private
documentary every single month like this
along with all our previous ones when
you join and there's a refund policy too
unlike most YouTube memberships
so if you join and you don't think it's
worth it email us within your first
month of joining for the first time and
we will personally refund you for your
first month after your first month there
is no refund so scroll down and click
that join button below now
thank you